foreign
[Music]
video games generate more money than the
movie and music Industries combined game
revenue is expected to approach 200
billion dollars this year according to
ampure analysis but unlike Hollywood
stars and musicians game makers are
mostly Anonymous to the general public
now a new book by one of Gaming's most
successful designers is offering a
behind the scenes account of the
industry's rise Brooks Silva Braga
traveled to Raleigh North Carolina to
meet up with this self-described control
freak
so I mean this is literally me
as a teenager like planning out the 2D
Adventures that I did back in the day
right Cliff blazinski started making
video games when he was 11. that's uh
initial sketches of uh Jazz and the bad
guy Devon show converting sketches into
pixels on the family PC you know I
wasn't getting any dates at the time so
what I wound up doing is just pouring
myself in my computers and making video
games by high school he was selling a
floppy disk versions of the games
through the mail and you know the checks
just kept showing up and I started
really realizing like I I love doing
this but I can also make a little bit of
money doing it how many games do you
sell it was enough to you know make me
be able to quit McDonald's so I'll tell
you that somewhere between Prodigy and
self-promoter Cliff blazinski might be
the Forest Gump of gaming there's
blazinski in the first edition of
Nintendo Power Magazine with the highest
a possible score in Super Mario Brothers
[Music]
1990 15 years old now playing in the
finals of a Nintendo World Championship
competition in Boston
we got all the classic consoles that you
can play but the industry and blazinski
quickly grew Beyond Nintendo in Sega
barely out of high school he was hired
by epic games and created jazz
Jackrabbit a hit on desktop computers
then unreal a series of first-person
shooters that expanded the ability of
players to compete across the internet
all the while Cliffy B nurtured a
swashbuckling Persona that landed him on
MTV Cliff is a media [ __ ] and he loves
it
your camera is followed as he made Gears
of War the Cinematic brutally violent
game that launched the Xbox 360. this is
uh the first Gears of War with a hero
battling dad issues let's see if I get a
chainsaw killing here and a chainsaw
attached to a gun oh I hear it there we
go I'm just curious like what you see
that other people don't when you're when
sitting in front of the screen I see
something that was created when I was
going through a really rough patch in my
life a lot of the best art that I've
made throughout the course of my life
has been when I was miserable yeah a lot
of people say that all kinds of artists
really weird the way that works in his
new Memoir control freak blazinski
traces his success capturing adolescent
audiences to his own Arrested
Development in one terrible year his
father died suddenly and an online
acquaintance molested Cliff my childhood
came to a stop he writes and so did I
Frozen seemingly Forever at age 15. I
mean if you look around this house us
you know I have a life-size R2D2 and
bb-8 I mean seriously like I still love
comic books I still love Transformers
it's that kind of trauma can really kind
of freeze a person to some extent I
assure you I've been to my share of
therapy the confessional nature of the
book was another form of therapy and
facing myself blazinski candidly
describes Gaming's frat house office
atmosphere in the early 2000s including
his own shortcomings leading to a failed
first marriage you know I Was a Serial
cheater
I was good at hiding it too but one
thing he's not willing to apologize for
is the violence in his games where the
possibility all those virtual bullets
help Inspire real world shootings our
video game's the factor I honestly do
not believe that I've been asked this
question for 30 plus years and that's my
stance and I'm sticking to it is it not
fair to see it as a little convenient
that even as you're making all this
violent content you insist no no no no
no it can't possibly have any impact on
the people that consume it I mean it's
a similar thing to maybe blaming
McDonald's for obesity like you don't
have to eat in McDonald's every day
after 20 years cooking up games for epic
blazinski grew tired and Rich enough to
leave just as importantly he had someone
to leave for I was like no you're it
you're my finally home like you're
you're the person you're my forever
person in 2012 he sent a flirty email to
programmer Lauren berggren it said
what's up cracka how you been and I'm
like who is this guy and why but after a
few months of dating she agreed to move
across the country for him come moving
with me and travel with me and play
games with me all day and do whatever
you want to do and for 10 years that's
been their life Lauren is a twitch
streamer now it's game players more than
game makers who are the stars of the
business these days blazinski's effort
to start his own Studio done out of
boredom he says now failed in 2018. and
why didn't it work out boss came uh how
long you got the video game industry is
a Fickle Beast you know these days if
you're not on the front page of the
streaming site twitch you're dead in the
water and so blazinski is looking for
other places to invest his time and
money how many viewers are we talking
over 400 oh my goodness Guinness World
Record he's already a part owner of the
Raleigh beer garden all right cheers
cheers and a producer of the musical
Hades town okay so what's next you have
a
working on a comic book more Broadway
musicals as blazinski writes in the book
this is just kind of a nerd Shrine as he
sees it the Nintendo boy won you're at
47 now the same age your dad was do you
have any thoughts on what he would make
of what your 47 years have been like I
came to peace years ago with the fact
that he'd be proud of me
the kicker though that I struggled with
for years was the fact that if he hadn't
died I wouldn't have this career he
would have forced me to go the standard
route of going to Northeastern
University becoming an engineer just
like him having kids the whole nine
yards and so the the Silver Lining again
to his death is that I was able to go
down my own path and for a control freak
picking your path
maybe the Ultimate Prize for CBS
Saturday morning Brook silver bracket
Raleigh North Carolina
wow that's a realization that you had to
go through the hardship to get out on
the other end yeah book sounds
fascinating I want to check it out I
know and it's interesting we were
talking about this before the video
games just what a massive industry it is
and you don't think about it enough